[Music]
and milk wars news
got milk okay I can't drink milk No
submitted by the chef show the chef the
chef chef ro right Roy
Gweneth Paltrow Wow thirsty Stephen
Colbert Colbert yep
you some naming names with having Joshua
OCA oh hello America's largest milk
producers at Dean Foods files for
bankruptcy oh I wonder why cuz like if
they're producing milk that it's
probably they making a lot of money
because it's like all dairy right so
they dairy they own multiple companies
some so it's like an umbrella group so
here are some names you might sound
familiar
dairy pure true Moo everybody's favorite
Land O'Lakes butter Oh can't believe
it's not butter dude Lehigh Valley dairy
farm okay not sure you buy and be hi
Lehigh Chinese thing about so jeans made
of milk it's great the old farm sound
I'm not sure about that one
but it comes because of a very sour cuz
the article wrote sour sour year for the
milk in this time other ly
disappointment I don't even pretend like
that's not a joke you would to you it's
my father
I've only upset cuz I didn't say it
table we gotta ignore all their I'm glad
we've isolated them so net sales in 2017
or a fourteen point seven billion
okay you guys take a wild guess where it
was in 2018 less than that teen point
wait what year was one year difference
when your difference and they started at
17 billion they're at fourteen point
seven billion a year was that 2017 at 17
I think is bigger before so now in 2018
Oh probably drop you made a drop oh yeah
I dropped well I'm just gonna throw out
a number I'm pretty sure the low in this
belief let's just say like five billion
drops to five billion six billion I'm
gonna go for 46 million damn
Donald [ __ ] Terry wide range I think
Josh might be closest really yeah I
figured it is that 1.1 billion Oh
Wow they did net loss 50 billion lost
1.1 they went down to 13 points that is
still a lot though I was like I would
say no matter how many like other milks
there are dairy goes in so many other
things yes we're just milk but I still
think I like thinking with that 1
billion dollars in us it's not a small
amount of money but it's still way it's
like it's less than 10 percent is enough
for them thinking like trending for the
future it's only gonna keep going that
they had this debate this the board
decided to file for bankruptcy
interesting only one yeah I think it was
declining fighting last year was the
biggest decline within a year what's the
benefit of filing for bankruptcy where
people can't collect on payments and you
like loans yeah so they have that many
loans out with a million won't cover the
cost compared to what they might I think
Billy it might not be liquid for liquid
they might have your liquid for that
much money god dammit they initiated a
chapter 11 file chapter 11 bankruptcy
which quote-unquote researchers to
continue serving our customers and
operating as normal as we work toward
the sale of our business so which means
they are selling the business to a buyer
interesting out of probably a lower
price than what they're valued at
because they are bankrupt but so it's
not like a loan thing right it's like
what since this bankruptcy I believe the
government does help you continue to
operate until you find a buyer think
that's how so it's like a cash out thing
it's like all right before this dives to
two deep they're like we want out of
this we're gonna collect we are selling
it yeah right you're selling the right
the profits and run you're pretty much
losing the whole business but you do
your employees keep their jobs well I
mean the ones that don't get immediately
fired when they that's where like
layoffs happen and whatnot so what's the
reason why they did though the reason
why is because is it for reasons no no
actually it's because of the huge sore
in plant based dairy products but could
not milk milk
milk and 1 year from June 2017 of June
2018 or a 52 week period non-dairy milk
like products kind of accident sales
went up to 23 and 51 percent
respectively with oat milk about 23% and
any other non-dairy rising up by 51 so
like soy cashew milk almond cashew
cheese is pretty good issue that's the
closest thing to like regular cheese get
cashew cheese if you go to like if you
go to like biology or plays or anything
geez they use as cashew cheese like
vegan cheese yeah like nachos and stuff
with cashew cheese on it's the cheesiest
tasting like melon cheese cheese cheese
cheese on dairy product based cheese
yeah most cheese vegan cheese products
are made from a cashew butter milk do
you guys drink I don't know I don't
drink nonfat lactaid yeah I'm allergic
my throat closes I'm Asian you're Asian
yeah motivations aren't good with
lactose they get yeah what does 70
percent 80 percent and as you age more
people just get mine isn't bad I'd
prefer just not even the model
discomfort yeah yeah bloated my throat
closing cakes or anything no Marian does
like if she has like some kind of drink
with like powdered milk it you know or
whatever it's like bad but for me it's
like uncomfortable I guess just rather
Nelson's response to every it's okay
take your time
yeah well yeah I don't know I just
rather not if yeah we have the option
not to these games sometimes it just
doesn't like it's not the same they'll
like ice cream especially like it's
pretty hard to give up ice cream yeah
but lacked it like lactaid lactate has
been an amazing thing know what dairy
still and then lactate if anything makes
it sweeter mmm keen ice cream in it
what's that kid it's a brand but then
it's like if you take as a pill you can
eat whatever the area things you want
but they make nope - yeah so the milk
they break down the lactose in there -
like sugar is this yeah yeah no I don't
like lactate I grew up drinking that
mainly because of my mom and she told me
up a cup like a tall high cotton milk
of hottest black tape milk and I had to
drink it before school every single
[ __ ] day and I [ __ ] hate the taste
but I'm not even lactose oh ha but in
regular milk you're fine with drinking
I'm 100 %
tastes that much different notation in
Turkish you had to drink it every day or
you don't know the difference man it
tastes weird I don't like it I mean you
being a Cartman we make Giulia cry of a
milk I'm getting heated up right now
just just like your milk it is not
regular milk it does not taste like
regular milk yeah Nelson did that move
you Julia it's sweeter and she don't
like that I think that much of a
difference so the company has received
around 850 million dollars in that what
they call depth or in possession
financing which is a type of financing
for companies like this that are in like
bankruptcy / like financial distress
mm-hmm so I'm assuming that 850 million
is like that cash loan or whatever to
help them keep operating until they find
a sale but they're hoping that the sale
does allow for higher than that amount
and trade oh yeah so that's that's their
goal right now and this says right here
that of the company has approximately
15,000 employees across the country I'm
wrong it's a big-ass industry it's great
yeah yeah
so Mike I'll be kind of the practices
but is there a silver lining out of this
you know what I mean like is it all is
it good that we're staying away from
dairy you know there's always uh
interesting things about this because in
every industry right has a [ __ ] ton of
workers whether or not you like it and
like you you want that industry to not
be there because it bad practices
whatever but then there's like humans
who are just trying to get by yeah
that's like that's like health insurance
you look at [ __ ] meat industry where
they're like doing terrible things there
or like dairy industry it's all like I'm
not I don't prove of what they do but
clean time this this humans work yeah I
mean what's the easy solution right
they're not all like it's not all like I
feel like yeah they do
there are things that are bad within the
industry but I also don't feel like it's
it's it's just so black and white two
categories the entire no entire thing is
like it's like all
dairy industries all super [ __ ] up and
stuff saying all the media industry
super [ __ ] up like there's things that
I don't like about it but yeah I have at
the same time too it's like I do like
the problem we didn't have a JK party
video where you just taste a bunch of
milk we're all gonna get like really
gross almond milk I can drink it but
anything else really lactose intolerant
I can't drink
no you're lactose intolerant I don't
think so I just hate the taste of I've
always hated it if I'm having to drink
it all the time huh my mom would make me
drink so much milk and then you'll beat
all way through my prayers look who's
taller than you we're just like soy
milks healthy we're gonna drink soy milk
all the [ __ ] time yeah and then after
a while they were just like I don't like
what's in slow mo we're going back to
regular milk I don't like what's what's
agents way mo is it just like the Vita
soy like that oh maybe maybe you had
really bad soy milk
I might have no I did but I did enjoy it
I love that [ __ ] I think sugar like a
super sweet yeah yeah you're at a hot
though yeah yeah it's a very specific
kind of flavor though sometimes it's not
into it and I want like normal milk
we're also like he needs some milk
Oh milk though if you guys haven't tried
open milk [ __ ] try I like taste like
it it tastes like oatmeal but the
leftover oh I don't know why I don't
O'Neil juice that's that's what the milk
industry actually wanted people to start
calling it not juice
because they know that calling something
nut milk or milk sounds good yeah and
they didn't want that so then they were
child petition to make juice this is
milk
you guys are juice this is not juice and
they're like what I'm gonna call that 9g
that's pretty nutty that's pretty fun
and I saw that they created rice milk
like I know there's rice drinks that's
been around for a while I heard about
rice milk though that's been oh just
pour the milk through the race and then
just like that's like or chocolate
basically my mom drinks a lot of flax
milk too flex flex yeah Oh very healthy
yeah it's a lot of making that yeah so
but I mean ultimately out of all the
alternative milks I like oat milk the
best I'm really tired of soy milk
because I had a lot of like silk and
stuff like yeah but you built your big
boat
meal fan I like oatmeal I don't eat
oatmeal very often that's what I like
well yeah if you only go in the prana
you like it so
dude I don't know if you what you owed
me oh man well I've seen one I like
oatmeal what I say it but but it's like
oh meals like some people just eat by
itself like nothing like you gotta put
some like brown sugar
I've seen someone put cheese on their
slice of cheese why did I can mix it up
that's weird I've had salt on my oatmeal
before that's I feel I can tell you to
buy like a pinch of salt that's kinda
like gives it flavor but if I'm trying
to be healthy I'll just be plain salted
oatmeal or whatever I go peanut butter
honey nothing dude with bananas yeah
that's really healthy
nectar ice we only add some dried
blueberries on there and then it's like
[ __ ] Byron who orders poki with no
sauce what a lunatic what it was also
great goal-oriented Yetta you know very
laser focused goal on one and that's why
he looks so good on party yeah onions
[Music]